～♪星に願いを　はじめver♪～
こんにちは！
バン！
終わった...
終わった！
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです！
今日の夜ご飯です
僕！
白ごはん大好きなんですよ！
それもびっくりするくらい
引くくらい好きです
聞いてください！(強調）
やっぱ、白ごはんってそのまま白ごはんを食べても
やっぱあんまりねぇ、こう味っ気がないとおもうんですよ
そこで！僕は思ったんすよ
ふりかけとかね、いろんな物をかけるわけですよ
ごはんには
で、かけるんですけども
何が一番おいしいかと思った
と　き　に　！
ぼくはまた
（キラーン✦）
ひらめいてしまった！
世のなかには、調味料というものがたくさんある。
コンビニにある調味料コーナーのやつを
全部買ってきました！
（商品置きの舞）
（振動）
バン！
なんか、、、使ったこともないやつもあるですけど
僕は思ったわけですよ！
軽い味付けでごはんは美味しくなるんで、
全調味料を集めてね、
風味のある
味わいのある
健康的で
おいしい
完璧な調味料を作り出して、
それをご飯にふりかけて食べると、
史上最強においしいんじゃねぇかと、
僕は思ったわけなんですよ！
ハヴルァクs！！
ちなみに、ごはんはこれです。
もう先に温めるよぉ！猫舌だし。
では作っていくよー！
これ、あの、なんか、あれですよ。
今後、俺ん家で何かを食べる時に、
味付けがもうこんだけあったらなんでもできるからね。
じゃあ、こん中に順番に調味料入れていきましょう！
ちょびっとずつでいいんすよ！
まずはこちら、
ポッカ100レモン！
プｒァｆ！！
でも体によさそうすねぇ。
塩コショウ！
これは至ってスタンダートっすね。
あぁなんか、今回期待できるぞ！
悪くないと思うんすよねぇ、線は。
コンソメ！
コンソメって個体なんだ・・・
豆大豆醤油！
ｋァ！
マヨネーズ！濃口ソース！
OLIVE OIL!
搾りたて醤油！味ポン！
中濃ソース！ウソトーソースォ！
ファ゛ｋｋ！フドゥォア！
とんかつソース！リセッタ！
・・
・・・
これは違うなぁ。
リセッタは違う！
純正ごま油ぁ！
フォァアッハ！！
醤油ぅ！濃口醤油！
あああ嗚呼唖あゝ！！！
ｳﾜｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ↑ｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ！！！！！！
ちょっと醤油の分マヨネーズ追加で。
オリーブオイル　エキストラバージン！
すし酢！ゆずポン酢！
マスタード！ナチュラルチーズ！
焼き肉のたれ！
あれぇ~まだオリーブオイルあんの？
減塩醤油！味の素！
七味唐辛子！白だし！キムチ！（？）トマトケチャップ！
生姜焼きのたれ！一味唐辛子！アジシオ！
ラー油！タバスコ！
って言ってそんな辛くないんすよね。
（後悔）
ｱｱｯ･･･!
ｱｱｱｱ!ｳｩ･･･ｳ･･･ﾊｧ!ﾌbｧ
ﾊｧ･･･ｱｱ､ﾊｧ↑!
ﾊｰ｡
生すぃつぃ！
ｙｚずこそぉ！
pフｒり！パフォｘイ！ｒオーｎア！ホフrrrrr！
ｒオウzアk！ゥヲｘオ！本田翼！
トゥｚアダヤヤ！
ＯＫ！！
完成しましたー！
できました！こちらが！調味料全部混ぜた最強のふりかけでございます！
はい！
（悪寒）
世の中見た目じゃないんだよ。
というわけで、ごはんが完成したので早速！かけて食べてみましょう！
お！！富山県産のごはんだやったー！
ホカホカのごはんでございマース。
果たして、まぁなんかでも、やってる感じ的には
そんなに悪い感じではなかったんですよ。
特別まずいものでないじゃない？調味料って
基本的にねー
はずれではない気がするんですよ。
全てが混ざった調味料！
かけていきます！
ドドン
はっｗｗ
ま　じ　か　ｗ　ｗ
まぁまぁまぁ、まぁ！
大事なのは味です！
じゃあ、いただきます！
（いただき
ません）
こわいｗ
ん！？
あらら・・・？
ああｈあぁぁ！
えええぇぇ！！まじで！？
んんぬ！
まって、まって、まって！
（鼻をすする音）
おいしい！！
俺がおかしいのかな…
・
・・
・・・
待って！とまらない！
はｗｗあのー、すげーおいしいです。
なんだろぉ！！？？
ごちそうさまでした！
あえて例えるなら・・・
異次元級のおいしさの卵かけごはんの味がしました。
えー、こちらの方にレシピ載せておきますので、
ぜひ、皆さん作ってみてください！
じゃあな！！